who are the people who choose to come
and work at the sec you heard in my
little
introduction there this is something i
think about a lot i've i've been served
papers
exactly once by the sec when i was a
little bit younger a little bit
terrifying i'll tell the story without
saying any of the names um but i take it
deadly seriously because i think
these are very smart people with legal
degrees and accounting degrees and
who've gone to incredible institutions
and there's this private sector here
where they would
absolutely be compensated much better if
they were in the private sector so
explain to me why you chose to go work
at the sec
and why do you think people choose this
vocation
as opposed to maybe one optimized for
generating more compensation well i came
to the sec
first as a member of the staff and my
job was to review
to write rules for mutual funds actually
and and so that was a
learning experience for me and i came
because i really wanted to see
how a regulator worked from the inside
and specifically
was interested in the securities markets
and so that's what drew me there and i
think for a lot of people
the the draw for coming to the sec is is
they do believe in the capital markets
just as i do
i they have this firm belief that
capital markets can
improve people's lives and so they want
to be there to
work on setting that that solid
regulatory framework
um and so i think that you mentioned
principled and i think people do come to
the job
with these principles that they're
trying to live out
and it's also just a great group of
people to work with so i think there's
that element of it too it's it's a
really
really nice organization and and we have
lots of people who have spent
their whole careers or virtually their
whole careers at the sec
which reminds me in a way coming from a
family with a lot of law enforcement uh
in it from the state department to the
fbi to the new york city police
department
that i hear that a lot from people who
co-work in law enforcement they feel
like they're doing something virtuous
and good for society and it's
intellectually stimulating
when we get back from this quick break i
want to talk about
the accreditation rules which is
something that i deal with a lot and it
seems to me to be something
that coming from a a background
in which i grew up poor to maybe the
bottom of the middle class
the accreditation laws which we'll
explain when we get back felt unfair to
me
i happen to be one of the lucky people
who was able to break through the
accreditation laws
and get to a level where i could make
private investments
and then once i was able to make those
private investments i was able to
generate
let's just you know be candid here a
large amount of personal wealth
and wealth for other investors but
looking at it now
i wonder deeply about the fairness of it
all
because i i see a lot of people who
couldn't make that jump